our goal is pretty simple I want to help
you get what's in here and just splash
it onto there don't worry it's not
rocket science
it's harder
thanks for going to a special place with
me
Carl
got it that tree is probably too tall
brace yourself you are going to get some
calls
oh my God
it is an
user wait what's going on
friends and welcome to paint with
Ambrosia it takes paint to a whole new
place and it's been a lot of places good
night everyone
never seen him that mad
[Music]
Ness
Don't let Fame bring out the worst in
you real man
never looks back
new tote bags it's only because yours
weren't selling you're lucky I'm an
artist instead of a woman who says
really mean things to other women you
were an artist
the real artist follows his heart my
Uber is here I don't know what that is
it's goodbye
how's everything going awesome watch the
image tucked away in your brain that
makes your heart ache and your soul feel
like it's going to burst
[Music]
yeah
Carl is one-dimensional and very sexist
you know I don't care what people say
about me
[Music]
PBS Burlington
yes we're aware that Carl is stealing
newspapers please hold